today's questions from Alisha in
Kentucky is it okay to have your three
to six months emergency fund in a Roth
IRA no your emergency fund is not an
investment your investments are not
emergency funds you do not want to use
your retirement funds as your emergency
fund I understand that technically you
can pull the money out it's not a
technical issue the problem is your
habit patterns and the way you view the
money you need a rainy day fund that is
earmarked to be used for nothing except
rainy days it does not make you any
money but insurance doesn't make you
money insurance cost you money to
protect the things that go up in value
and so quit trying to find a way to
shortcut everything and lay out basic
foundational financial planning
principles you need a rainy day fund of
three to six months of expenses not
invested parked in a simple money market
account earning almost nothing it
absolutely sucks it is not there to make
you rich it's there to protect the
things that are gonna make you rich like
Roth IRAs that you're getting ready to
cash out to fix the transmission in your
stupid car and now you don't have a
retirement that's dumb no we're not
going to do that it'll leave the things
alone that make us wealth and we're
going to put up fences around them to
protect them and that's called insurance
one type of insurance is your emergency
fund not an investment insurance
investments make you money insurance
cost you money to protect assets defense
and offense or how you win games
you don't win games only on offense if I
could win games only on offense I could
have out earned my stupidity and I tried
it for years I can make money like
nobody's business I've always been able
to make money it was the keeping it part
that was killing me and that's how I
went broke most of you listening to this
make a ton of money but you're broke and
that's just because
all you think you think I'm going to
keep making more if I just get another
raisin we get a $500 a month race and we
go get a 600 ollar car payment celebrate
dumber than a rock then people do it
every day every day and you're making
eighty-five thousand or one hundred
eighty-five thousand dollars a year and
you're freaking broke no you have to
play defense and you have to play
offense you put the proper might kinds
of basic insurance in place
homeowners car auto auto insurance those
kinds of things you put an umbrella
policy in place if you're starting to
build a little wealth and you're getting
up close to your millionaire status your
everyday millionaire status you put
basic life insurance in place eight to
ten times your income on you to protect
your family from the loss of your income
until you have so much money that they
don't care if they lost your income
that's called self insured at that point
you put the basic insurances in place
and one of the basic insurances is not
technically insurance but it's grandma's
rainy day fund you know what grandma
said you needed a rainy day fund because
grandma was old grandma seen stuff come
at her she didn't think it was gonna
come called life she had seen it rain
and she knew you need an umbrella I'm
getting old I've seen every possible
stupid human trick I think that people
can do to get themselves in a pinch and
I got to tell you it changes everything
when your heat and air goes out and
you've got some money set aside it turns
a crisis into an inconvenience but if
you've got a freakin cash out your 401k
to put a heating air unit on your house
that I mean your Roth IRA that's just
suicide you just shot yourself in the
foot you're going to walk with a
financial limp now don't do that